JOHN: Thank you
guys for joining us.
My name is John [INAUDIBLE],
I'm from the YouTube team.
I'm so excited to be joined
by Alan Masarek who's
the CEO and co-founder
of Quick Office, which
got a nice little shout
out today at the keynote.
And we're here to talk about and
answer one question, but really
just dive into the nitty gritty.
And that is after you've
designed and developed
a product how do
you distribute it?
How do you get it out there?
And hopefully we can
share Alan's journey
but also help
provide some insights
in getting your products
and apps out there
when the time comes.
So Alan, so good to have you.
Thank you for joining us.
ALAN MASAREK: Thanks for having
me, John, I appreciate it.
JOHN: Awesome.
So why don't you tell us a
little bit about Quick Office.
I know it's definitely
saved me when
I've been on the road
trying to change an app,
trying to get in on a
last minute deadline.
So you've definitely
helped me there
but talk about how your
product has helped thousands
upon millions of
people every day.
ALAN MASAREK: OK, so the
company we pittered a bit from
our initial founding back in
'02 but by '05 we had settled
on sort of this
mobile office play.
And for those of you
unfamiliar with the product,
Quick Office was
architected to be
compatible with Microsoft
Office but on mobile.
And what that meant is that
if you had a Word, PowerPoint,
or Excel file, and ultimately
in 2003, 2007, 2010 formats,
you could open it into the
Quick Office data model.
We had full editing features and
you could round trip it back.
And when you opened it, you
could render it faithfully
so that the paragraphs looked
the way they were supposed
to, the PowerPoint looked
the way it was supposed to,
et cetera, et cetera.
The market
opportunity for us was
that Microsoft had
restricted Office
in mobile just to
the Windows platform.
And so we started way back in
'05 in the Symbian platform.
And back then, we
all forget today,
it had 80% of the
world's smartphones.
And then obviously
it lost its share
relative to iOS and Android.
But we ported iOS and Android
from Symbian back in the day.
So as John was
saying, and you got
to start with a
really good product.
You got to design it and
you got to develop it,
but that's only half the battle.
So at the end of the
day, distribution
is what set Quick Office apart
and where we really won from.
We ultimately shipped
on a pre-loaded basis
with the handset manufacturer
on 500 million units,
starting back in
the Symbian days.
So where we sole sourced
Nokia and all of Symbian,
but Symbian was largely
Nokia, we later had about 2/3
of all Android
volume because we had
direct relationships with
Samsung, and HTC, and Motorola,
and Amazon, and the Kindle Fire,
and Barnes Noble and the Nook,
et cetera, et cetera.
In every instance we always
shipped our product branded.
So it was always
branded Quick Office.
And so while we never had an
embed relationship with Apple,
our brand was
extremely well known
and people needed Office
support in mobile.
And so we did
extraordinarily well
in Apple, initially
on the iPhone
and then later on the iPad.
I mean as the smartphone
market was growing and growing,
we were doing very well.
But then enter the
tablet and now you
had a canvas, which
was large enough
where you're going to do
real work while mobile
and we just took off.
So that's kind of the story.
And I can share with you other
things on the distribution,
but really a key
attribute for us
was getting in people's hands.
JOHN: Absolutely.
And I think it's
so interesting, you
mentioned multiple
different platforms there.
Nokia, the Apple store, Android.
And I think the amazing thing
about the Quick Office story
is that you've survived
for so many-- I mean even
PalmPilot back in and day.
You've been around for so many
ebbs and flows in the industry
as we've moved from mobile
phones to smartphones.
And so what's been
the key of continuing
to put the Quick Office
brand and product out there
though the platform has
shifted so many times?
ALAN MASAREK: I think that if
I was to advise entrepreneurs
it's when our
companies are small,
you've got to kind
of hitch your wagon
to people that
kicked a-- I always
like to refer to them as
big brother partners who
care whether you live
or die as a business.
And so in the earliest days,
we cut a deal with Nokia.
And quite frankly some of
this was a bit of luck,
we had started in Palm but
then produced a Symbian version
in the early days.
We happened to be
headquartered in Dallas
and Nokia's US headquarters
were in Dallas.
We created some
relationships there
and cut this deal where we built
Quick Office into the
Symbian stack itself.
So if you built
a Symbian device,
we came with automatically.
What was really important
is that what we forget,
back then there was
no frictionless path
to get to the customer
like there is today
with the iTunes
store or with Play.
Back then there were
hundreds and hundreds
of little small app companies
but there was really
no good aggregation in
order to build a brand
or build name recognition for
a globally distributed product.
So while the smartphone
market is far larger today
than it was in
2005, it was still
a big globally distributed
market back then.
So the deal we cut
with-- and so it
shipped into the four
corners of the globe.
We're a little company, we
don't have a marketing budget
in order to build awareness
all over in multiple languages.
So we built in-- they
were actually languages.
They required us to
localize in 55 languages
because they shipped
throughout the world.
And we cut a kind
of a sweetheart deal
with Nokia where we
gave them the viewer--
you know ours is a viewer
and an editor-- we gave them
the viewer for a
really cheap price.
But the quid pro
quo of that deal
was that we could
serve up our editor
to the device
anywhere in the world.
So all of a sudden
we had sort of
solved this
distribution conundrum
which had tripped up all
these other mobile companies.
No one had scale.
Back then there were hundreds
of little tiny mobile companies.
And we're back
there again-- there
are hundreds of little tiny
mobile companies, or thousands.
But there are hundreds of
little tiny mobile companies,
there was like nobody with
more than a million dollars
in revenue because
you couldn't scale.
There was no way to
get distribution.
So that embed deal changed that.
And actually we were able to
go finance on the back of that.
Sorry for the long winded
answer but we went to Mayfield
and when we did our
first institutional round
in the spring of '05, it's
Mayfield's tier one firm
and the bet was there were
tens and tens of millions
of smartphones out there,
if we could get 1% of them,
of the user, to
upgrade to the editor,
we were going to build
a big revenue base.
So that was the bet.
And we scaled with
Symbian, but Symbian just
had its challenges,
it ultimately
was more or less replaced.
But then we realized
that quickly we
better jump on the iOS train
and jump on the Android train.
And we did hard.
And which again had its own
complications and costs to it,
because for Android we
had to rebuild in effect,
because it was a Java code
base versus a C++ code base.
But then we replicated the
exact same distribution model
and cut the same type
of distribution deals
with the manufacturers.
Made a big difference.
And you know, when
you're embedded--
and I go back to this
notion about big brother
partnerships-- they've got
to ship that smartphone
with Office support.
What do you do when you
get an email attachment?
You got to have Office support.
So they cared whether
we lived or died.
So it made a big help
for us as we scaled.
So that's kind of an overview.
JOHN: That's awesome.
So, Alan, take me through the
details of the negotiation.
You talk about these
big brother partners
but when you're sitting
across the table from them
and they're like
no, Alan, we think
we want to re-brand Quick Office
to be more of our platform,
Play.
No, we don't like
that rev share,
we think you should take less.
We have more of a
distribution network.
How do you fight against that
when you're just a startup
beginning and how do you
push back and get the deals
that you did to put you in
the place to make the exit?
ALAN MASAREK: That question
is a really important one
because when we're early in
our company's development,
there's all these moments
of truth that start early.
Ours was initially with Nokia.
Nokia was like we're not
branding this Quick Office.
We don't know who the
hell Quick Office is.
And we fought back.
And what's kind of ironic,
the way we ultimately
convinced them to
brand it Quick Office
was to protect their downside.
Basically if our application
wasn't very good,
people would be their
customer would be blaming us
as the app company
as opposed to them
as the device manufacturer.
And once we were branded there,
and again that was a big push
back, but we really
fought hard to make sure
that we were branded
Quick Office.
Once you get the first
big one-- and Nokia was
the 900-pound gorilla
back in the day-- then
with each successive deal--
like the Android deal was HTC.
HTC did not have a
lot of market power
when they were doing the
very first Android phone.
They did the G1 for Google and
then did their own devices.
So this is a very
nascent market,
it was an easier discussion in
order to get our brand there.
And then you build
momentum and then
the brand is actually
a high quality
and they want the
brand on the device
because then it conveys
high quality for the phone.
The other side in terms of
partnering to your question,
with the handset
manufacturer is when
we would preload the
viewer, we want the end user
to upload-- from the end user's
perspective, it's a freemium.
We're trying to get them to
download the premium, which
is generally the editor.
How we can get the big
brother partner, the OEM,
to partner with us was
really, really important.
Because if you could
get the UI kind
of a warm and welcome, warm
and welcoming sort of the UI
so that it prompted somebody
to want to buy the editor,
our conversion rates
were much, much higher.
And so we cut deals
with all these guys
where we would give them
a percentage of the upside
of that editor upgrade
in exchange for letting
us do things like
point of need updating.
Meaning when someone
tried to edit
and they only had a viewer,
it would prompt them
and say you don't
have those rights,
here's the purchase
mechanism to get them.
Those little things made a
huge amount of difference
for us to continue
to sell the editors.
Ultimately from a
distribution point of view,
we did not want to be an OEM
software company because the VC
community, no one values an
OEM software company very high
because you're always
going to get pressure
on pricing over time.
And we got some of
that, although it
was pretty sticky
on the way down.
We wanted to build
relationships with the end user.
And so over time you're
seeding the market.
And our revenues in OEM were
much higher than our revenues
with the end user.
But then the end user
far outshipped the OEM.
So it's like planning
that Trojan horse made
a huge difference.
And so by the time
we sold in 2012,
our end user revenues were
double our OEM revenues,
and growing much more quickly.
JOHN: Alan, is there
an example of an OEM
that you were really
excited to partner
with to expand your
distribution network
who maybe it didn't
go so well, maybe
there was a glitch
in the negotiation.
Is there a story
you could share?
ALAN MASAREK: Well, I guess
one quick story and that is HP.
You know, when Palm
was still independent,
Palm had their old
operating system
and then they
developed the WebOS.
And they released some
of their own products.
This is back in the time
when Motorola was coming out
with the early Android
products and Palm just
didn't get traction.
It's sort of interesting.
It came down to literally
Verizon putting more marketing
dollars behind
Moto's Droid program
than Palm's program on WebOS.
So they had to sell
and they sold to HP.
So we cut a phenomenal
deal with HP
we thought because we were
like believers in WebOS.
And for those of you who have
been around just three, four
years, HP put a ton of dough
behind it, huge release,
this thing's going to be the
greatest thing in the world.
It's going to displace iOS.
And six weeks into launch they
killed the entire program.
So we contractually
protect ourselves
but so we didn't get
too hurt money wise,
but it was a problem.
You made a wrong bet.
We bet on the OS
that didn't survive.
And we made a lot of smart bets.
And I always say you just
try to bet or bat-- excuse
me-- bat, B-A-T, with
a high batting average.
You're not going
to win them all.
JOHN: That's right.
That's right.
So Alan, you've had so much
experience distributing,
like had your ups and downs,
more ups obviously than downs,
but is there something
that you see nowadays
that really frustrates you when
you see a great product that's
just sitting on the
shelves, that you
think young entrepreneurs and
product developers should think
about in trying to
get their product out?
ALAN MASAREK: Yeah, I think that
there's a tightrope we always
have to walk as
underfunded entrepreneurs
and that's between building our
community, building our user
base, and revenue.
And frequently there's
sort of this bias
that we got to generate
revenue in order
to get interest
from the investor
community but that
sort of cuts both ways.
And so it's how you go
through and build distribution
in as obstacle free
a way as you can.
Because those first couple
million dollars of revenue
are going to look awfully thin
if they don't scale really
quickly, versus if you've
got 20 million users.
And so the challenge
all the time
is how you can be as
obstacle free as possible
in order to build
that community.
I mean you see it in
the social web all
the time in social networks.
More business oriented apps
that we were-- prosumer
focused apps, a
little different.
I mean I used to think
back all the time
when we were developing
some new products about
if we could give the editor
for free we would kill it.
But I couldn't
figure out where we
were going to monetize
in the back end.
And I still sometimes
think back about that
and maybe we should
have done the editor
for free and just kind of
thrown caution to the wind
because we would've had
mammoth penetration.
Because Microsoft basically
left this market open for us.
There was one example back
when the Kindle Fire came out,
they paid us a one
day-- you know,
it wasn't that much money--
a one day free sale.
All you can eat.
On Kindle Fire there were I
think 4 or 5 million units
outstanding at the time.
Our app that one day was
downloaded 325,000 items.
And we made peanuts
on a per unit basis.
But it helped us in a
whole bunch of other ways.
But free and things like
that really move the needle.
We played it all sorts
of alphabet-- you know,
A, B testing on pricing and
ours was a very high price app.
But even if you took
it down to $0.99,
the difference
between $0.99 and free
was still stunningly different.
JOHN: Alan, it seems like you
champion the freemium model.
You talk a lot about
the viewer, the editor,
and talking about
up-selling the user.
Do you feel like the
freemium model has its place
in terms of business
and productivity apps?
Or do you feel you
feel like it should
be applied with social apps.
This big movement that's coming
out is capture the eyeballs
and monetize later.
Do you feel more apps
nowadays in trying
to get their product out there
should be freemium model,
or what are your
thoughts around that?
ALAN MASAREK: You
know, that's funny.
I'm almost embarrassed
to say that I'm
a big believer in
the freemium model.
And the reason I say that is,
you guys are younger than me
probably for the most part, but
back 14 years ago in the bubble
when Jeff Bezos was on the
cover of "Time Magazine,"
it was like revenue
no longer matters,
it's basically eyeballs.
And that seemed like
heresy at the time
but you really were getting
rewarded for the eyeballs
not the revenue.
And I'm basically,
unfortunately,
are inherently saying
the same thing again.
Again, the other day we had a
good revenue base as a company,
but you got to get to that.
You have to have a
revenue base ultimately.
But you've got to
build momentum.
And so clearly it's used
in the consumer side
but I've seen the freemium
to premium model used,
I think, more smartly of late.
I mean back just a couple
years ago sometimes
you'd see people that they'd
give a crippled version
of their thing, a crippled
version out for free.
And that never made most sense.
And what I mean by
crippled version,
if you had sort of 10
pieces of functionality,
you'd only turn on six.
And it made very little sense
to me to give somebody only six
of ten, basically give
them a rotten experience
and ask them to pay to
get a good experience.
That never works.
So today you see increasingly
people give the full 10,
they just limit the number
of times you can use it.
But you want people to
experience your app fully
and love it, be delighted by
it, and then they'll pay for it.
But obviously there's all
sorts of different models
how to skin that cat.
JOHN: Of course.
So before we open it up to
questions from the audience,
I just want to ask is there
any other piece of advice,
any negative insight
from all your experience
that you would just offer to
somebody who is building an app
and just trying to get it
out there, like approaching
partners and trying to
reach the end consumer.
What would You tell
them from all your years
of experience that
could help out?
ALAN MASAREK: I guess
a couple things,
quick things come to mind.
This whole thing on financing.
I'd rather be
looking at the money
than looking for the money.
You're going to burn
through more money
than you think you are.
Every time.
The other side is,
I was referring
to this on those big
brother partnerships,
that first deal
frequently is going
to look pretty grim from
the financial terms.
You'd be very
fortunate if it didn't.
And I remember in
that Nokia deal,
they put a liquidated
damages clause in there,
because they gave us source
code because we were actually
putting it into the stack.
If there was an unauthorized
release of source code,
I think it was a liquidated
damage of 5 million Euros.
It was basically just
the death penalty for us.
And we looked at it and we
couldn't get them to change it.
And [INAUDIBLE]
said, we just said
we go to do it because
we needed that deal.
And the thing, it would
have been mutually assured
destruction ultimately
for them as well
because they needed our stuff
once we were embedded in there.
So there is a tendency to
fight for legitimate terms
in the first deal, but
you need that first deal.
So sometimes, again, this is
part of this whole velocity
notion, is dealing with
some grim terms early
to win the things that
are important late,
like your brand, I
think in hindsight
were the correct decisions.
JOHN: So with that we're going
to open it up to the audience.
We have a microphone in back
and we'll pass it around
to anybody who has questions.
Raise your hand.
This other guy's got
a ton of questions.
AUDIENCE: You sold in 2012.
ALAN MASAREK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So first question
is, why did Microsoft
choose to be able
to set this model up
where they weren't in the
game doing it themselves?
And the other
question is, when you
sold what was the
reason for selling?
I mean, what's next and
why do sell now versus?
ALAN MASAREK: Yeah.
So the first part.
Why didn't Microsoft
do this themselves?
When it was just a phone
space the principal use case
was a viewer.
There was very
little editing done
on a smartphone in the early
years of smartphone world.
So it probably wasn't worth
Microsoft's time to do it
because in order for them-- to
move the needle at Microsoft
you need hundreds of million
dollars of revenue and such.
So staying away from
the market made sense.
Now, when Microsoft had
90% of the given computing
environment, when you'd
only think about it the PC
perspective, they still had that
almost monopolistic position.
Now when you sort of
factor in phone and tablet
and now their share falls
to like less than 25%,
it's critical for them
to go cross platform.
So they had this sort of
schizophrenic challenge
where are they a platform
company with Windows
or are they a software
company with Office
and other applications?
If you're a software
company, you've
got to go cross platform.
But that ongoing
fight inside Microsoft
tended to reside with
Windows for years,
up until Satya just
became the new CEO.
And he said we've got to go
to where our customers are.
They sort of held-- when they
came out with Surface they held
back yet again
thinking it would,
leaving client Office on the
Surface would help Surface
relative to the iPad,
and it really didn't.
So they had a lot
of decisions to make
that created an opportunity
for companies like ours.
Second question
about why we sold,
we had already had commercial
relationships with Google.
We had done one in 2010,
another one in 2011.
They've come to us
about buying us.
It was very compelling, a
lot of things, financially,
and all those sorts of things.
But I hesitated because I was
having a heck of a lot of fun.
Things were really working well.
And we had excellent revenue
base, about 300 people.
We were really kicking it.
And I'm always
proud to say in 2011
82% of the days of the
year, 82% of the days
in the year we were a top
10 highest grossing app
in all categories in iPad.
So we were really doing well
and I was having a lot of fun.
But ultimately I couldn't
bound the Microsoft risk.
People used to come up to me and
say Alan, you're Quick Office,
you're Microsoft
Office on an iPad.
And I used to say well,
we're more than that.
But my worry was what happens
when Microsoft Office came
to the iPad, which it did.
So Google's been a
perfect partner for us
because now we're
built into Chrome,
both on the OS and
the browser side.
We're built in
Android with KitKat.
And you just saw the release,
they were built into Docs.
So it's been a perfect match.
JOHN: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Alan.
I had a question on a
quote that you said.
First of all, my name is
Johnny Bashem from Arizona.
And it's nice having
this intimate interview.
It's kind of cool.
You said, who is that said
it's not about monetization,
it's about eyeballs?
You said that was
Amazon who said that?
ALAN MASAREK: It was Bezos.
AUDIENCE: It was Bezos.
ALAN MASAREK: On the
cover of "Time Magazine"
like in the year 2000.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So it's interesting that
was like a game changer.
Everyone's like what is
this guy talking about?
And obviously, look
at where he is today,
look at the success
of the company.
And then immediately I think
of companies like Snapchat who
are just like rampant
with users and now they're
starting to make innovative
steps towards monetization,
but I think today
still no monetization.
But they do have stuff
like watch EDC live.
And now they're engaging
huge amounts of users.
What do you say
towards companies
like that is the first question.
Second question is what is
that next like unbelievable
breakthrough?
Like just as if Bezos
said back in the day,
it's not about monetization,
it's about users.
What tomorrow, what's going to
be the ridiculous statement we
see on "Time's" or
TechCrunch or whatever
that is just as like
unbelievable or just as true
moving forward?
ALAN MASAREK: A great question.
I don't know if--
let me sort of answer
with a couple of examples.
So if you think of this massive
community Snapchat has built,
and now they're thinking
about monetization.
Think in the early
days of LinkedIn.
LinkedIn didn't know
how it was going
to monetize what is it,
like something like 3/4
of LinkedIn's revenue
comes from the recruiter
side of the house.
Viber.
I was just in Europe last
week and I was using Viber.
Viber, you know is
completely free.
But I could-- and all these over
the top solutions are free--
and I could buy some
extra emoticons,
just send crazy smiley faces.
And that's like that first
introduction of payment.
In each of those
instances those companies
have built massive value
based upon the size
of their footprint and the
number of engaged users.
And you'll find
the revenue model.
Now, you can't forget
that at the end of the day
there has to be a revenue model,
there has to be from someone.
It may not be Snapchat
as an individual company,
it might be acquired by
someone else who then
can monetize those
eyeballs somewhere.
I mean even look
what Google does.
Google has lots and
lots of free services
but it monetized that with
a very unique ad model.
So you know what's
the next next?
If you're only going
to get paid on--
or if you're only going
to get valued on eyeballs?
You know, I think
it's interesting.
It's like it could be
even some retrenchment
before we get to the next
because it wasn't long
after Jeff Bezos was on the
cover of "Time Magazine"
like he was man of the year
or something like that it all
busted.
And evaluations
came crashing down
and there was incredible
illiquidity in the market
and you couldn't raise money.
And it sort of returned to like
let's build real companies.
And now the pendulum seems to
go the other way yet again.
And people have short
memories and companies
without revenue models are
getting funded for astronomical
sums.
The only thing I know
for sure is not all of
them are going to come out the
other end of that bottleneck
as successful companies.
AUDIENCE: So when Microsoft
introduced BPOS and eventually
Office 365 and it
opened up SharePoint
to quite a few SMBs that
now have the opportunity
to access their
documents in the cloud.
Did you guys do anything
to use that to help
grow or did it hinder the
growth of the application
that you guys offered?
ALAN MASAREK: That's
a great question.
It didn't hinder
us at all because
in the early days of
BPOS and then Office 365,
Microsoft really
had to protect kind
of the mother ship of
the Office franchise.
So if you remember
in the early days,
you had an online viewer
but not the editor.
Or then the editor
was very rudimentary,
or the conversion of their own
stuff in the cloud was poor.
The fidelity was poor.
So they were sort of dipping
their toe in the water
and the data was noisy for us.
But it concerned us as
they were coming that way.
They were trying to manage, or
they continue to try to manage,
a move from a perpetual use
licenses to a subscription
world without screwing
up their revenue base
because they got to
report to the street.
So it's really
challenging for them
to disrupt themselves that way.
We went out and we sort of saw
this-- Sundar talks so much
this morning about the
multi-device world.
We live in a multi-device world.
You're going to begin work
somewhere on one device
and edit on the
next and it doesn't
matter where you author
and edit and vice versa.
At the end of the day,
you're just moving,
you're moving around
devices and devices
across multiple operating
systems as well, generally.
And so we had developed a
product that was a cloud
version, or cloud
stored version,
that would then push, like
in the old BlackBerry push
metaphor, down to the devices,
trying to sort of develop
a new product that we thought
would stay ahead of everything.
But again, what we came out with
right before the acquisition,
so we'll never know how
well it would have done.
AUDIENCE: So I'd like
to tap your knowledge
base about startups
and entrepreneurs
and just in general
about the marketplace.
I seem to have a penchant for
finding opportunity and not
knowing how to
monetize it or not
being able to identify the
threats that I could be exposed
to by entering that marketplace.
So I'm curious in
your experience,
if you see an
opportunity if you know
when it's right for someone
to jump in the market,
how do know where that
threat's going to come from?
And can you give me any insight
as to how to monetize something
that you think is maybe a bigger
players and enter the market
and take that big piece of
the puzzle out for small guys?
ALAN MASAREK: Yeah,
great question.
I think as one
entrepreneur, and I've
done three-- I'm kind
of a serial entrepreneur
guy-- so I've done three.
And I think this applies
to most entrepreneurs.
The problem is not being late.
The problem is being early.
And Quick Office, we were early.
So that's one sort of big risk.
You're just out
there and you see it
but the market takes a
long time to develop.
So that's a big threat.
Clearly you've got-- you know.
When you start
something you rarely
know how deep the hole is.
The idea seems really
compelling but you
don't know until
you get into it.
And so you've got
to be really careful
and really scrub
the idea before you
start spending real dollars
doing it because you want
to know how deep that
hole's going to be.
I was reminded not long
ago, a guy came up to me
with this incredible,
crazy idea that he
was going to do,
use drones to do
aerial photography of farmland
and then algorithmically
or whatever and come back and
diagnose your crops in terms
of-- and I thought this is the
craziest thing I ever heard of.
It's not a world
we live in at all.
Talk to a buddy of mine.
So my point is talk to experts.
Talked to a buddy of
mine whose venture
firm focuses on agriculture.
He's like ehh, I saw
three of those last week.
So there's very
few original ideas.
That was the point.
There's very few.
And it blew me away.
I was like I never thought
of something like that.
And just reminded me
that there's very few
original ideas.
So it's how ripe the market
is, how well you execute
against it, making sure you
got enough money to do it.
You know, the vast
majority of us
die because we run out of money.
And so money is oxygen.
You got to have it.
So I don't think about the
monetization immediately.
I think about-- because it's not
to be profitable immediately.
I got to fund it.
And I'll go through the
angels and the whole bit
to try to fund the thing.
And also, a lot
of people also-- I
have a big thing about
phases of a business.
This is another
sort of thing I've
lived with for a long time.
I always talk about four
phases of a business.
So you have inception,
commercial viability,
repeatability of the
model, and then scaling.
I see people all the
time in businesses
in the inception
phase prototyping.
They're spending lots
of marketing dollars.
It's a complete waste.
As a matter of fact,
it's counterproductive
because you can win customers
and then disappoint them
on the experience
because the product's not
really commercially viable.
So making sure
that you stage your
spend with the stage
of your business,
or perhaps being slightly
ahead of the stage.
But all too often I see
people spending millions
of millions of
dollars on marketing
when the business
model or the product
itself is not even developed.
AUDIENCE: Obviously you're aware
of the Uber, Airbnb phenomenon,
right, that exists.
And there's obviously going to
be a lot of other businesses
that take from the group
think and the acceptance
of peer-to-peer rating.
What do you see as
opportunities in that space?
ALAN MASAREK: In sort of a
the shared resource economy
you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, shared
resource, crowd sourcing,
peer-to-peer evaluation.
ALAN MASAREK: I think it's--
crowd sourcing to me is really
powerful.
I mean all these-- this
notion of shared resource.
I mean clearly Uber,
Airbnb, I was looking
at another one a friend of
mine was talking about today
and something else, but all
the shared resource notion
is really interesting.
I'm actually involved as a
director of a company that
is involved in crowd
sourcing your contacts.
The idea is that,
again, so just think
of it sort of conceptually.
We have our contacts and they
sit in a digital database.
But they begin to decay
because people move jobs
and change phone numbers,
things like that.
So it gets more and
more obsolete over time.
And there's no
passive, automatic way
in order to update
your contacts.
It's as if you have something
in a digital database
that you tend to
treat no different
than an analog
database, like it was
business cards on a Rolodex.
So this crowd sourcing says
well let's put it all together.
And it's not like
I'm going to give you
someone else's contacts.
I'm just going to give
you back your contacts,
but from a machine learning
algorithmically in the cloud
you go through and have multiple
versions of everyone's contacts
so they know Alan Masarek is
no longer at Quick Office.
Alan Masarek's now at Google.
We've got the right guy
and his phone number's
changed to such and such.
So it's a way to update
people's information.
So I think crowd sourcing
is huge that way.
That you got to deal
with privacy issues
but I think you're going to
see more and more of that
because it just makes sense.
And that's just one
example because I just
think it's clearly a problem,
that one example in context,
is clearly a problem
that has to be solved.
And crowd sourcing
is the way to do it.
I don't know if I
answered your question.
OK.
Good, thank you.
AUDIENCE: It seems
like since you sold,
Microsoft has made a lot of
advancements in your space.
In addition to what
was announced today,
what do you think
Google needs to do
to remain competitive
and continue
to make an indent
in this market?
ALAN MASAREK: I actually
think Google's in a great spot
right now.
I'm not just waving the pompoms
as a Google cheerleader.
I would constructively
criticize from
before that the sharing model
was better than Microsoft,
in my opinion, before.
The whole notion of the sharing
model, real time collaboration
or not, just the whole notion
of how you save and interacted
on documents was better.
But for the longest time
the editing functionality--
or first of all, the convert
fidelity wasn't there
in Docs, Suites and
Slides, and then
the editing functionality
wasn't there.
And so you had to kind
of go through-- what
I mean wasn't there
wasn't kind of up to snuff
and it wasn't offline and
it wasn't mobile, et cetera.
And so in a sense
you had to kind of go
through an element
of pain in order
to get to the better
sharing model.
Now the editing
functionality is there.
You saw track changes.
You can stay in office
mode with Quick Office.
It's offline.
It's mobile.
And it's got more than
adequate editing functionality
for the 95% of the users.
So now you have, in my opinion,
an actually better solution,
the better sharing
model with more
than adequate functionality
on the editing side,
you have a one plus one
equals three situation.
So I think continuing
down that path,
which I've been pushing
like crazy in the two years
I've been there, they'll
continue to do that
and I think they will
win a lot of business
in the enterprise app space.
I really do.
JOHN: Awesome So with that thank
you so much for your questions.
And thank you again to Alan.
This was wonderful.
ALAN MASAREK: My pleasure, John.
Thank you so much.